it's not been the best of weekends for
the prime minister after a raft of
resignations from his top team so how's
monday morning looking for him his
wife's under verbal attack and reports
today of a delay to plans to fix the nhs
backlog the health secretary sati javid
on the show shortly plus we'll be
talking to the shadow work and pension
secretary jonathan ashworth it is monday
the 7th of february nhs backlog has a
last-minute intervention from the
treasury delayed plans to tackle it
a brutal campaign by bitter ex officials
boris johnson's wife carrie hits back
after being accused of meddling as the
prime minister tries to stem the flow of
tories turning against him
the french president is off to moscow
for talks with president putin still
hopeful that dialogue can prevent
further conflict here in ukraine
behind bars the children as young as 12
in overcrowded cells held by the taliban
our special correspondent alex crawford
reports from afghanistan
welcome back australia will finally
reopen its borders to all vaccinated
travelers this month after nearly two
years
and gun salutes for the queen we'll take
you through today's celebrations marking
her majesty's platinum jubilee
a new twist as tennis player pong shui
denies she ever accused anyone of sexual
assault in her first interview with
independent media
fa cup shocked nottingham forest knock
out the holders leicester while
non-league borum would reach the last
16.
also on the program for you this morning
we've skied over 400 miles to the south
pole carrying all of our own kit and
we're now standing on the highest
mountain in antarctica mount vincent
mission to the ends of the earth we meet
the disabled war veteran conquering the
world's toughest expeditions
striker pose will speak to a model with
down syndrome who's signed with a major
agency after being inspired by a vogue
cover really looking forward to chatting
to her and her mom a little bit later on
good for her
[Music]
morning everybody what a week it is
going to be for the prime minister one
of his right-hand men is with us hello
good morning good morning spoiler alert
no sue gray or met i'm going to mention
throughout the course of this what i
know can you believe it let's start with
the nhs backlog instead uh your plan
well the booking a treatment on an app
how does that work yeah so the
because of uh coverage the nhs is
rightly focused on covered patients and
it has meant sadly that the the waiting
list has has risen significantly and i
and i have to tell you i think the
waiting list is going to continue to
rise for a while until it starts the
fall and the reason
we can't be sure and the reason is
because we estimate about eight to nine
million people stayed away from the nhs
because they were asked to they did the
right thing but we want them to come
back we i want them all to come back
because i want them to know the nhs is
there it's open uh for them but as they
do of course that's going to create more
pressure and my job the nhs job is to to
get through that elective backlog that
code backlog as quickly as we can and
what we're announcing today is that part
of that plan will include a new online
service it's called my planned care and
it will mean that every individual on
the waiting list in england will be able
to see online exactly where they are on
the waiting list what the average weight
is in the area and other information
about how they can prepare for their
treatment the importance of this is that
understandably many people will be
anxious and stressful you know about
their position the weightiness is
perfectly
understandable and we want to provide as
much transparency as possible of course
alongside this there's lots else going
on we're investing a record billions of
pounds in the nhs to get through that
covered backlog including investment for
example in things like the new community
diagnostic centers already they've done
some 400 000 extra diagnostics they'll
do an extra four and a half million by
2025 so there's a lot of investment
going in i just want to make sure that
we're doing everything we can to help
people with their health and care no
matter where they live or who they are
and i thought for the families of those
that didn't make it because they were
waiting and sadly uh they've succumbed
to their illness well sadly of course
that that has happened i talked about
that
of course just on on friday when i
launched the a new
call for evidence for a new cancer plan
i want to do a new 10-year cancer plan
but when i talked about that and just
preparing for that you know we we think
there's at least around 50 000 people
when it comes to cancer that sadly
didn't come forward they haven't come
forward uh because of kovid and and in
some cases there's been devastating
consequences and a thought for the
families what would you say to them well
i think that
of course my heart goes out to anyone
that's been affected by that and their
families their loved ones their friends
and i i would just want to reassure
people that inside government working
with our friends in the nhs we're doing
everything we can to get services back
up and running getting them back to
normal
unfortunately because of the omicron
variant which we've all now obviously
all know about just in the last few
weeks that's had another impact as well
but we're we're getting on with this and
we will also shortly be publishing a
very ambitious your full elective
recovery plan okay i was reading in my
telegraph newspaper this morning that
the uh plan is the nhs backlog plan is
not coming today because you've hit a
roadblock with the treasury
well it's not coming today because we
had a roadblock with omicron omicron
where i had actually planned to publish
the plan in in december and we were
almost there we're agreeing it finally
with the nhs and across government uh
but because of omicron we've rightly
changed our focus especially to boosters
and to to focus on that and
we obviously did the right thing it
makes us now the freest country in
europe and we're heading the other side
of overclock but we will publish the
plan shortly the reason i ask that is
because matthew taylor who you know who
is
the nhs confederation has said on
twitter increasingly getting the sense
that johnson now faces the same but more
intense and short-term challenge that
tony blair had in his third term we've
got this graphic i think normally hm
treasury is loathed to agree to any
number 10 plans involving money and the
chancellor so um yeah what do you think
so they're suggesting that it's the
treasury that's the problem oh in fact
what i would say about the treasury is
that i couldn't wish for a better
partner when it comes to the challenges
that are this is wrong
i don't recognize that at all because
actually i i can tell you personally
from you having been chancellor you know
having a close relationship with the
treasury having a strong partnership for
any department is crucial and right now
for health and care i'm just really
pleased we've got that really good
working relationship you talked about
the nhs backlog getting worse before it
gets better when is it going to get
better
it's hard to know because of the the
people that have stayed away it's it's
really hard to put a number on that and
we i've asked that question myself of
course of our friends in the nhs and
they will rightly well they rightly will
come back to me and say look a lot of it
depends on how many people come back you
know what's the of those people that
stayed away the eight to nine million
what proportion of them you come back to
the nhs and as i said i can't be clear i
would like to say this if i can just
make clear to your viewers that if
you're one of those people that you know
for whatever reason you you weren't
feeling well and you stayed away from
the nhs because you were told to because
you did the right thing during the
pandemic you'll please come forward and
the nhs is there but it will of course
mean that the nhs will will
have to
rightly deal with that find the the the
investments and and the procedures to
deal with that but the record amount
that we're putting into the nhs that's
an extra 2 billion went in this year
just for elective procedures another 8
billion over the next three years that's
going to pay for something like an at
least an additional 9 million more scans
and tests and procedures
and we'll be able to you deal with many
many more people it's not going to be an
extra 12 billion a year into the
national health and um and social care
given that that's how much the national
insurance is yes i'm just referring to
the the money that's ring fence for
elective care of course the nhs does
does a lot more than that okay um is the
money that is from the national
insurance increase all of that money is
going to the nhs and social care not
going anywhere else
the levies all nhs and social care
forever
it's it's it's it was health and social
care it's broadly health and social care
so it includes for example spending on
vaccines but it won't be hived off
anywhere else it's it's it's a it's a
it's a health and social care so i heard
one of your colleagues at the weekend
saying for now
it's a health and social care levy the
the treasury's been very clear about
that okay um let's move on should we and
talk about um
jimmy savile
the row over jimmy savile has caused all
sorts of problems um the slur against uh
kia's dharma in fact one member of the
downing street team uh resigned as she
says
as a direct result of that should the
prime minister apologize to the labour
leader no i i first of all i understand
the sensitivities around this and this
is why the the prime minister himself
after he said what he said in parliament
has clarified his remarks and and really
i think that's all there is to this now
in that you know i think we should we
just try to move on from this there's so
much else that is going on and i think
that we should draw a line under this
issue and just try to move on because
the prime minister has come forward and
clarified let's just let's just remind
our viewers what he actually said in the
house of commons this leader of the
opposition a former director of public
prosecutions mr speaker
he spent most of his time prosecuting
journalists and failing to prosecute
jimmy savile
outrageous
well i don't know if you've got the
other clip which was i think a couple of
days later where the prime minister did
clarify his remarks he clarified he
didn't apologize and it's just
it's it's it's it's important that he he
rightly set out what he meant it doesn't
it's not you know i wasn't i wasn't
there responding to
the report so it the prime minister has
said what he wanted to say
and and subsequently he's come forward
and clarified those remarks and this is
what rishi sunak said
can we listen to that
here we go being honest i wouldn't have
said it and i'm glad that the prime
minister clarified what he meant so he's
happy to say that he shouldn't have said
it he's also pleased the prime minister
clarified the remarks i don't know do
you want to play the clip of the prime
minister clarifying the rocks
have we got that can we play that please
i think you're fine it's my show all
right okay well it's interesting you're
not showing that what we have got is you
here when he was running the the dpp
did a good job and he should be
respected for it it's a tough job and he
should
he deserves absolute respect
you're getting a bit testy about this
why are you so testy about it i'm not
i'm just saying that it's it of course
it is a sensitive issue i i get that and
that is why
these victims are furious that is why
the the prime minister rightly i think
it was just a couple of days later you
know made made it clear what he meant
and also what he didn't mean he came and
said that and that was right and and and
right now
you know hopefully you'll understand
your views on isn't this isn't the issue
that i'm focused on you know i'm not i'm
focused on my work at the department
which could not be more important we've
talked about we've talked about it quite
a lot so let's move it we've talked
about it quite a lot
but one member of staff who had been
loyal to the prime minister for 10 years
she stepped down because of the fact
that he wouldn't apologize even though
she told him to we heard what rishi
sunak said he says he wouldn't say it
you have said as we illustrated there as
well that you know kirstama has your
support why will this prime minister not
apologize when it's blatantly obvious
sometimes that he just should
well look i i can't add anything more
than i've already said he's clarified
the remarks and i think that's really
it's the right thing to do and i think
hopefully we can draw a line under this
because he's been really clear about
what he meant and what he did not mean
and that and that i think was really
important okay would you have said it
it's not about me it's not it's not
about me no it's not it's
in front of me i'm asking you would you
have said it no it's it's not about me
i'm not the one they're responding to to
the report you know i i'm responsible
for what i say and and i think i've been
very clear so mr sunak was wrong to say
what he said there but you have to get
mr sunak in and ask him well try every
week what can i tell you keep trying
yeah i will uh downing street has been
described as a dysfunctional and needing
a shake a shake-up dysfunctional and
needing a shake-up um how would you
describe dining street over the last two
years
um well we've achieved as a as a
government and obviously downing street
at the heart of that a lot has been
achieved i mean downing street if you
want to call it that or government more
broadly we have uh you know just
protected this country from communism
we've delivered on brexit no was it
dysfunctional no it's not something i
would have recognized but when my my own
work with downing street would have been
quite limited the but the changes that
are now being made is what the prime
minister he had promised this in
response to the update from sue gray
where sue grey herself i don't remember
the exact words in her in her recent
report but she had talked about the
fragmented relationship for example
between the
officers of stuff but in terms of
she said cabinet
downing street she talked about the
fragmented relationship between the
cabinet office and downing street and
the need to make changes so i think the
changes that the prime minister has
announced in particular the appointment
of steve barclay you're a very strong
individual very
but it is someone who understands the
cabinet office and now having that link
with downing street now
i'm not going down that rabbit hole what
i am going to say is uh reports say the
prime minister has told his allies that
critics will need a tank division to
oust him from number 10. it's an honor
to serve it's not a birthright of course
it's an honest order there's any any
minister well it doesn't just because
someone said that because i mean you can
hear him saying it
well i've never heard that so yeah this
is just some speculation
you shouldn't believe everything you
read in the press case i don't i don't i
don't also believe everything that
politicians tell me either
well moving on carrie johnson was your
special adviser when you were business
secretary you've seen the comments about
her in the book uh by lord ashcroft at
the weekend is this misogyny yes simple
yes it is it's sexist i mean it's
why
first of all i think the partners of
politicians should be off limits there's
no why would you go after attack the
partners of politicians by all means go
after the politicians but why their
wives their husbands or their their
partners because they encourage them to
break lockdown rules i suppose well no
this is
this is not what this is about this is
just about going after an individual i
actually do think it's there's a sexism
involved in this that's right i mean i
really do i i do think this and uh and i
i would i just think
doing this you know going after in this
case you're going after carrie johnson
is it's undignified it's unfair and it's
just wrong this is her statement
actually she she's put out a statement
or on her behalf um here we go yet again
mrs johnson has been targeted by a
brutal briefing campaign against her by
enemies of her husband this is just the
latest attempt by bitter ex officials to
discredit her i suppose that's a
reference also to dominic cummings who's
apparently going to make more uh
revelations later on today she is a
private individual who plays no role in
government you would second that yes
what do you think jerry blair played a
role in government do you think yeah do
you think do you think uh your normal
major she played a role in government
i'm playing devil's advocate because you
know i have no formal role in government
and so this is absolutely correct she
was a conservative party um she worked
in conservative party central office i
think previously so she she was she was
active within the party i'm trying to
play devil's i mean i i also don't she
she was as you say she was my special
advisor she was an excellent special
advisor but she's not in government in
any way uh he has no formal role in in
government and her
to the extent she would have any
anything to discuss with her husband to
do with government would be any
different from anyone before her so why
is she any different to anyone that came
before her as a partner of a prime
minister what would you say to lord
ashcroft and dominic cummings in the
like well i i i i would just say that
you know if you want to
you talk about number 10 these issues by
all means please do so but you know
focus on the prime minister
um
we all want to uh be successful in life
don't we we all have ambitions and goals
do you do you want to be
a leadership contender
you're going to tell me there's no
you're going to tell me there's no
vacancy
there's so many there and i've done that
and i'm just focused on my job and i'm
really as you said it's an honor to be
in government in any role it's a it was
an honor for me when the prime minister
invited me to take on this job at the
time that he did in the middle of a
pandemic and
and that is it's a privilege every day i
wake up and think of it as a privilege
and i do everything i can to help can
you rule out completely a leadership bid
i don't think there's going to be a
leadership election i really i don't i
don't think there's gonna be leadership
election because
we've got a leader in place
that's doing a excellent job he's
getting on with the job he's delivering
on all the commitments that we made and
i'm there to support him alongside the
rest of the cabinet can you rule out a
leadership bid there's no leadership
election it's good to talk to you thank
you very much for joining us i told you
i wouldn't mention sue grey or the met
yeah talk that one time thank you very
much it's great to talk to you thanks
very much uh quick look at what's
happening as far as the papers are
concerned this morning that story that
has now been debunked uh by the health
secretary the telegraph saying the
treasury has blocked a multi-billion
pound plan to deal with the nhs backlag
back log i don't know whose teeth i've
got in today hogwash says the
health secretary which was due to be
announced today the guardian reports
that half a million people face delays
in seeing a cancer specialist due to
overstretched nhs waiting lists
tory rebels could number 100 in any
confidence vote that's according to the
eye how would they know i suppose would
be the follow-up question it also says
the prime minister's wife has slammed
claims she has too much control over
government policy claiming bitter
ex-aides are behind the allegations
the french president emmanuel macron is
heading to moscow today for talks with
president putin he hopes an open
dialogue can prevent russian conflict in
ukraine let's get more on that should we
our security and defense editor deborah
is in kiev for us this morning um hello
to you deborah good morning good morning
um what's going to happen
well i mean this meeting is again
another bit of shuttle diplomacy which
we've been seeing an awful lot of over
the last few weeks but it comes on the
back of warnings from u.s officials that
russia now has about 70 percent of the
combat power needed where it to want to
launch a full invasion of ukraine and
also the u.s national security adviser
saying an attack in whatever form could
happen at any moment so really high
stakes as the french president heads to
moscow he'll be meeting like you said
with president putin he does still
believe that dialogue can perhaps uh
prevent further conflict he's also then
off the back of that meeting going to
come here to kiev tomorrow and at the
same time you've got the new german lead
leader germany and also a key player
here going off to washington today to
meet with the u.s president
okay thanks very much indeed oh the
weather looks horrible there deborah
yeah it's pretty miserable
i can see that go ahead and get a cup of
tea we'll talk to you the next hour
thank you
quick look at what's happening uh in the
next hour on the program speaking to a
cyber security expert about the
consequences for britain if that
conflict between russia and ukraine
develops
26 years on a confession from serial
killer levi bellfield over the murders
of lynn and megan russell could show
there's been a miscarriage of justice
speaking to the barrister and legal
commentator chris dawe
and could the pandemic be entering an
end game in europe the world health
organization thinks so we'll speak to
the who's special envoy for kovid19 dr
nabarro of course
meantime some good news to bring you
australia has announced plans to reopen
its borders to all fully vaccinated
travelers next week a week after a
fortnight today in fact siobhan is
standing by for us hi siobhan tell us
more
morning kay well we heard last week new
zealand setting out their timeline to
reopen and today australia has been
talking more about using its
restrictions so from the 21st of
february business travelers and people
with visas who are double jabbed will be
allowed entry to australia now the
double jabbing is really important
underlined by prime minister scott
morrison who of course made an example
of novak djokovic who he saw being
deported last month because he wasn't
vaccinated against coronavirus so you
have to be double jabbed if you aren't
you're going to have to present a
medical certificate and get an exemption
before you travel but good news here for
both the tourist industry and of course
the airlines as well who've been dealing
with one of the strictest set of
restrictions in the world since march
2020 and i don't think this easing is
any surprise really we've seen australia
dealing with its biggest coronavirus
outbreak since november despite the
restrictions and also it's worth bearing
in mind with any of these announcement
that this is an election year for
scotland morrison and of course more
lockdowns would be very unpopular okay
thank you shawn thank you also making
news for you on the programme this
morning gcse and a-level pupils will be
told in advance what topics will appear
in this summer's exams examiners will
also be asked to make their marking more
lenient this year because so many young
people have had their schooling
disrupted by the pandemic
police in the canadian city of ottawa
have made seven arrests from what
protesters are calling the freedom
convoy after roads in the city were
blocked with vehicles and tents they say
there are more than 60 criminal
investigations so far related to the
demonstration
foreign secretary liz truss has warned
china to respect the sovereignty of the
falkland islands
where we heard that before her comments
came after the chinese president agreed
a statement of cooperation with
argentina which included support for
argentina's claim to the islands
i should just mention at this stage
shouldn't i that if you were expecting
to hear from the education secretary
i'll ask the education secretary sadly
as you'll know um he did test positive
for kovid last week he has been quite
poorly so we couldn't um get him to come
into the studio obviously still
recovering from kovid today we're hoping
to do that
very soon indeed as soon as we have a
firm date we will let you know what we
can tell you about though is that gun
salutes are taking place at midday in
london and edinburgh today to celebrate
the queen's platinum jubilee iva
standing by for us at the wellington
barracks in central london hi iva good
morning why are you there
hi morning kay so yes today really marks
the start of the celebrations in this
platinum jubilee year there'll be gun
salutes at various locations uh midday
in green park and that'll be a 41 gun
salute carried out by the king street
royal horse artillery who are based here
at wellington barracks now they've been
up since four o'clock this morning
polishing all their gear soon they'll be
tacking up their horses they are at the
moment the troops having breakfast but
the horses are over here this is
windermere hello girl
she is one of 71 who are taking part
she's been showing us a lot of interest
since we've been here this morning and
now as i say there'll be gun salutes at
various locations also in scotland and
edinburgh and also at the tower of
london now the queen herself to mark the
occasion she was at sandringham state
yesterday from where buckingham palace
issues a series of photographs showing
her majesties working from her
red boxes those official ministerial red
boxes
emphasizing i think the fact that
despite her recent health concerns she
is still very much an active working
monarch even after all these years on
the throne 70 years on the throne a
platinum jubilee
okay thank you thanks a lot obviously
we'll bring more of that to you
throughout the course of the day here on
the sky news including that gun salute
now there's a new twist in the case of
the tennis star punch way who has denied
that she ever accused anyone of assault
i'm sure she did maybe she didn't tom
standing by for us tom tell us more
morning okay well just to remind you of
this whole saga in november punctual put
a post on weibo chinese social media
saying she'd be sexually assaulted by
jan gowli a very high-ranking communist
party official that post was removed her
account was censored we didn't hear from
her for two weeks and she has been
making reappearances since then but they
always seem to be tightly controlled
what's happened today is that la keep
the french sports paper has the first
independent uh media interview with her
uh and she's gone a bit further we have
heard more details so just to take you
back to that november post on weibo
punxsuit wrote that i didn't agree to
have sex with you referring to jan
gowley and i kept crying that afternoon
she totally keep i never said anyone
sexually assaulted me now she hasn't
denied writing that post and it's a bit
frustrating there wasn't more follow-up
uh in that interview to ask about the
meaning of those words she uses this
word be in chinese which means pressure
or force or compel but it probably
doesn't meet the definition or the
common understanding here of what
constitutes sexual assault but we didn't
have that follow-up and this was a very
tightly controlled interview there was
an official from the chinese olympic
committee sitting in l'keep had to send
their questions in advance they're still
these questions about how free whether
she is under duress uh when it comes to
speaking to media there have been these
appearances every one of them reveals a
bit more detail but perhaps raises
another question rather than answers
okay i can recognize the bird's nest
they're behind you famous during the
beijing olympics 2008 of course they're
hosting the winter olympics at the
moment aren't they
they are and they had the opening
ceremony at the buzz nest here again on
friday night and it is now in full swing
there's been a lot of action today
already the first story i think for uh
british viewers as well would be uh
kirsty muir who's um only 17 17 years
old has done fantastically well she's
qualified
for the final of the ski big that's the
huge jump over in the west of the city
where also eileen goo who's become the
face of the olympics she was america she
was born and raised in america
before switching allegiance to china
she'll also be competing in the finals
there was disappointment for another
american skier um katie trophen who uh
sat she was defending her olympic title
but crashed out she didn't finish so she
won't be able to
go for gold or compete any further but i
think you know one of the better stories
we've heard is that of uh canadian
athlete max parrot he won the golds in
the men's snowboard
slope style which is a fantastic event
sort of combine all sorts of tricks only
three years ago he was diagnosed with
cancer he went through 12 rounds of
chemotherapy and he described his
winning run as the best run of my life
fantastic um i'm absolutely riveted to
the games as usual and particularly the
curling is that your sort of area of
expertise there tomorrow i don't want to
put you on the spot
i wouldn't say i'm an expert color it's
getting quite popular here in beijing
team gb will also be taking part in that
today we already knew there in the
semi-finals
they had another match against the usa
which they won pretty comfortably and
that means they'll be facing norway
who beat them earlier in the group
stages
although that match didn't count for as
much so that for them is an opportunity
to lock in silver at least and maybe
give them a shot at gold
okay see there's nothing this man
doesn't know thanks tom
we're used to upsets in the fa cup
aren't we and the less fancy teams
didn't disappoint me
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
a wild and windy weekend weather remains
changeable this week with signs of a
colder spell settling in
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
also this caught my eye actually over
the weekend is quite a crafty little
parrot this one in new zealand there you
go
what he did was he land he actually
stole the gopro
uh it was a camera from a family resting
during a trek and in the process gave us
a stunning bird's eye view
of the fjordland national park in new
zealand
eventually the parrot lost interest and
dropped the camera and the owner found
it soon afterwards how cool
is that
morning top stories for you the health
secretary says that the nhs backlog will
keep rising before it comes down as
plans to tackle the crisis are delayed
after a last-minute intervention
intervention from the treasury
in other news the french president
emmanuel macron will today meet with
vladimir putin in an attempt to find a
diplomatic solution to the growing
crisis between russia and ukraine
and australia says it plans to fully
reopen its borders for the first time in
two years to fully vaccinated travelers
tomorrow's here another monday another
challenging week for the prime minister
he had all sorts of resignations to deal
with last week didn't he where is he
with the contenders who might want his
job and who definitely he's got rid of
them
morning yes turbulent end to the week
for the prime minister his policy chief
munira mirza who's worked with him for
14 years announced she was quitting over
this issue of what the prime minister
said about jimmy savile or more
specifically his refusal to apologize
that resignation letter got leaked and
then a load of other officials who we
expected to go perhaps as a result of
the partygate scandal all out of the
door quicker than expected so the prime
minister lost his head of communications
he lost various other key people in
downing street we've had a couple of new
appointments over the weekend which he
hopes will help to reset things and bed
in this new team what about a leadership
challenge it's interesting i was asking
javid he said that you know he he gave
me the line about yeah no job uh
opportunity no job vacancy at yada yada
but he was definitely not
completely ruling himself out didn't
completely rule himself out of course he
ran last time and i think the prime
minister just waits to see whether the
threshold of letters comes in we had
another two over the weekend uh one from
uh charles walker mp another one from
you see nick gibb who's fourth uh from
the left uh on the top row the he's sort
of unassuming former schools minister
these are not people who are constant
critics of the prime minister you know
in tv studios all the time it doesn't
seem to be particularly coordinated but
these are all the mps all men actually
who have so far confirmed
and including caroline notes at the top
there could letters of no confidence
having gone in but um they
there may be many others behind the
scenes who have because they don't have
to tell us this is a secret process and
if we hit that number 54 then there will
be a vote of no confidence somebody
takes down a street brace for that right
somebody else who's behind the scenes um
to all intents and purposes is carrie
johnson and she's being criticized again
in the papers at the weekend uh she used
to work for sajid javid of course didn't
she and i did put to him whether he felt
well this is what i said to him
is this misogyny yes simple yes it is
it's sexist i mean it's
why
first of all i think the partners of
politicians should be off limits there's
no why would you go after attack the
partners of politicians by all means go
after the politicians but why their
wives their husbands or their their
partners because they encourage them to
break lockdown rules i suppose well no
this is
this is not what this is about this is
just about going after an individual i
actually do think it's there's a sexism
involved in this that's right i mean i
really do i i do think this and uh and i
i would i just think
doing this you know going after in this
case you're going after carrie johnson
is it's undignified it's unfair and it's
just wrong
so this is the response to a new book by
the conservative peer lord ashcroft
called first lady which is about carrie
johnson as being serialized in a major
newspaper and he's claiming that she has
undue influence over the prime minister
is trying to control everything in
number ten and in the words of lord
ashcroft her behavior is preventing
boris johnson from leading as
effectively as voters deserve there's
been quite a storm of criticism about
this book including from sajid javid who
used to
have carrie johnson working for him when
he was communities secretary saying well
look this is on the prime minister and
mrs johnson can't defend herself mrs
johnson's spokesman actually hit back
this weekend saying that she was a
victim of brutal briefings by her
husband's enemies and she's had quite a
lot of support including from michael
gove's
ex-wife sarah vine who says you know
this is in the end about the prime
minister and his judgment okay for now
tomorrow thank you tomorrow's take at
nine o'clock looking forward to it now
with tensions between russia and the
west worsening over threats to ukraine's
border cyber security experts via
britain could fall victim to cyber
attacks if moscow decides to invade
professor kieran martin is the former
head of the national cyber security
center and he joins us now hello to you
thank you for joining us on the program
this morning how worried should the uk
be about cyber attacks from russia
thanks for having me i think in the last
month both the u.s and uk governments
have issued warnings effectively saying
be on heightened alert but stopping well
short of trying to spread
panic i don't think it's likely that
russia will do something completely
unprecedented
towards the uk
that it hasn't done before but
there are two real risks one is as
tensions mountain of russia does take
further military action in ukraine you
can expect that to be accompanied by
heavy cyber attacks against ukraine
we've been caught up almost literally in
the crossfire of those before when
they've gone a bit wrong and they've hit
networks in the west and caused large
amounts of economic damage the other
risk
is that russia harbors an awful lot of
very damaging cyber crime we see that
with hacks on british schools local
authorities we saw it on the irish
healthcare system
last year the u.s energy system
and russia can take its foot off the
neck of some of these criminals
sometimes if it suits them and if they
are in a state of tension with the west
even greater tension with the west than
they already are then they can perhaps
passively encourage some of these
criminals to cause us a little bit more
discomfort so it's a time to be
alert to cyber risks but not one but not
panic
how common are these cyber attacks do we
always hear about them
well there are a whole range of cyber
attacks ranging from sort of pretty
common petty criminality which sometimes
you hear about when they cause
disruption but a country like russia can
do very sophisticated attacks in several
ways it will do very sophisticated
spying and you can expect that all the
time particularly at a time of tension
now and that can involve commercial
interests as well as uh government um
interests
russia does do something it's called
pre-positioning it's just a technical
term for lurking in networks so that if
tensions get worse they can perhaps
exploit those so there's a full sort of
range full spectrum of cyber attacks
ranging from the very basic to the quite
um sophisticated and they are at it all
the time
but they're at it for particular reasons
and those things potentially get worse
and hopefully they don't but if they do
and we have to be prepared
there will be severe cyber
activity against ukraine and that has
potentially repercussions for us
how easy is it to tell whether it's
russia or north korea that's responsible
for cyber attack
it depends what it is so if there was
one of those very um damaging cyber
attacks like taking out an energy plant
which um or taking out power supply
which russia has done at least twice
against ukraine in kiev in 2015 and
2016. there are very few countries that
have both the intent and capability to
do that because that's that can be
that's quite hard to do
um so if russia was to launch a very
deliberate disruptive attack against the
uk it's probable it's not certain but
it's probable that we could detect that
it's uh russia
some of these more criminal attacks the
attacks where criminals try and extort
money but that disrupts health care or
education ordinary business they can be
harder to prove now we know over pain
painstaking analysis over a number of
years that a lot of it comes from russia
but it's easier for russia to deny that
sort of um attack so it depends it
depends what it is
okay it's good to talk to you thanks so
much for the explanation thank you
thank you
now another eyewitness report from our
special correspondent alex crawford uh
on what life is like for those who've
dared to stand up to the ruling taliban
in afghanistan political opponents are
now imprisoned or have disappeared and
children as young as 12
find themselves behind bars alex sent
this report from inside harap prison in
western afghanistan
the taliban now run the prisons and
we're given rare access to the main jail
in herat
the prison governor wants to show us how
well the taliban are running their
justice system
and we're escorted by him and his gunman
the entire visit
the men here have all been deemed
criminals by the taliban
the cells we're shown have around 40 men
jammed together
many have been here for months already
and they're accused of stealing adultery
not paying debts and fraud
the prison governor is behind us so they
answer our questions cautiously
but one with a fresh injury tells us
many are employees of the former
government
he says they've been put here without
proof or trials
the governor tells our interpreter not
to translate before we're moved on
we're being told not to ask them any
more questions
and
to leave
the taliban promised an amnesty for
those who worked with the foreign troops
or the government they toppled
but our evidence suggests this is not
being applied
instead there are widespread claims that
those now behind bars
are only there because of multiple
vendettas being carried out instead
the governor used to run a secret
taliban prison before they came to power
his office may be different but human
rights groups are worried he's using the
same old techniques he and his men are
implicated in the disappearance of the
female governor of the women's prison
alia razizi disappeared more than four
months ago and she's not been seen since
and the governor admits to us he
personally rang her to come to work
he says he's no idea where she is but
insists she was corrupt and she's
probably claimed asylum elsewhere
alia azizi's family are frantic about
her they knew her prison uniform made
her a taliban target
her career portfolio shows how closely
she worked with the foreign troops once
based in afghanistan and her husband
utterly refutes all the allegations
against her i got made up
if she was going to leave she'd have
contacted me by now he says it's all a
lie
he's gone to the capital to try to find
her the taliban warned him not to talk
publicly about her now he's decided he
has to
[Music]
at first we thought the taliban had
changed he says but they're the same old
taliban doing the same things
god only knows what's going to happen to
our country
there's still worrying evidence that
human rights continued to be disregarded
we found children locked up in hirat
prison too
what did what did you steal
asthma was killed a bicycle he says a
number of others said they too had been
locked up for weeks for stealing bikes
we don't like nothing he says and while
children are locked up and those seen as
taliban critics continue to disappear
inside these prisons there'll be
concerns
over those holding the power in this
country
alex crawford sky news afghanistan
[Music]
and we'll have a special edition of sky
news tonight focused on the crisis in
afghanistan featuring more of alex's
reporting and asking how the world can
help save the country from collapse
that's afghanistan the fight for
survival sky news tonight special at 7
pm
26 years ago mother and daughter lynn
and megan russell were murdered as they
walked down a country lane in kent
known drug addict michael stone is
currently serving a life sentence for
their deaths but now serial killer levi
belfield has confessed to their murders
so what happens next barrister and legal
commentator chris dawe is with us hi
chris thanks for joining us where do we
stand legally on this what happens next
now belfield has said what he said
well first of all i mean i think
everyone will appreciate that the police
and all of the authorities will act with
considerable caution on the the word of
a convicted serial killer the police
describe him as a manipulative
narcissist and i i i imagine that that's
a hundred percent on the money uh in
terms of the process the there is an
appeal for michael stone already sitting
with the criminal cases review
commission stone of course was
originally convicted and then he was
cleared on appeal and then convicted
again on a retrial and has attempted to
appeal on several occasions in the past
but this is clearly new material the
criminal cases review commission will
consider it they will of course consider
whether and indeed the police will
consider whether an interview with
belfield is required and ultimately the
police in particular but also the
criminal cases review commission will
have to make a judgment as to whether
this evidence is credible or not so they
will be looking at the fine detail of
what he's saying to see whether he may
have got information from the public
domain to does he want to fabricate a
confession because let's not forget that
belfield has nothing to lose he's
serving life without the possibility of
ever being released a whole like term so
he could confess to a thousand murders
it's not going to make any difference to
him
so they're going to have to check very
carefully whether the story that he
tells matches the evidence and matches
evidence perhaps that's not in the
public domain but there really can't be
much of that left because of course of
those two trials that stone has faced
over the years
yeah uh what even if he it has got a
full life tariff why would he confess to
a murder that he hadn't done
well people do i mean i've been involved
in in cases over the years where i had a
case where someone was serving eight
life sentences
and admitted to other crimes in which
frankly he couldn't possibly have been
involved um and people do um for all
sorts of reasons in belfast in
belfield's case as the police said he's
a narcissist he loves attention he
enjoys the publicity weirdly and
perversely and so you can't put anything
past him i mean this could be just
something that he that he's you know
summoned up on a sunday morning to try
and get some
publicity and of course he's been very
successful because we're having this
conversation now but equally of course
from the stone point of view stone has
always processed his innocence it's very
rare actually for people in stone's
position to maintain their innocence for
so long in the face of trial after trial
and year after year in prison that's a
very unusual situation so you have you
have the situation of one person
protesting his innocence that's going to
have to be looked at very carefully but
you have to have a very significant
caution around whatever bellfield might
say
yeah either way spending the rest of his
life in jail
thank you very much for joining us on
the programme thank you
now could it be the beginning of the end
for kovid in europe the world health
organization says the continent could
soon enter a long period of tranquility
in the pandemic they say this period of
higher immune protection should be seen
as a cease-fire as opposed to the end of
the war joining us is the who's special
envoy for the global covid 19 response
and chair of global health at imperial
college dr nabara of course hello to you
doctor it's always great to see you it's
the ceasefire but not the end of the war
is that how you would see it in europe
good morning kay yes i i must say that i
find myself quite
quite connected to these comments i mean
everywhere in the world is experiencing
kobed in slightly different ways right
now it all depends on what the virus is
doing and how people are able to respond
and and where they are and right now in
europe it it does feel as though things
are moving into a better space i mean
what really needs to happen is that the
system to deal with infectious diseases
works and it works behind the scenes and
we get fewer surprises it means that
everywhere people who are at risk should
be protected with vaccines that there
should be a a routine effort to prevent
transmission where it's building up
and that at the same time we prepare for
the surges and so yes if we can get that
system constantly working and do it
invisibly then it will be a period of
tranquility it won't be cease fire
because the virus is still there but it
will be really enlightened and smart
defense
how are these vaccines and boosters
getting on against the um
kovit and and at the various variants we
know that a senior uh cabinet minister
um has had he's totally vaccinated and
yet he still contracted it
yes so the new variants can break
through
and infect people even when they've been
vaccinated and in some people the
protection from vaccines wears off a bit
quicker than others we've known that
about these sorts of viruses before and
so inevitably there will be some
breakthroughs the great thing is that
the vaccines that are in use right now
actually prevent people from getting
severely ill and really reduce the risk
of death so we've got a way of making
sure right now that people are much less
likely to die when they get covered and
that's part of the tranquility that the
who european regional director referred
to the other day
i think you told me last time we were
chatting that one of your grandchildren
had contracted covet how are they doing
yes so the grandchildren are fine the
family is all well but i must say that
i'm sure that viewers will appreciate
what my experience and that is that
kovid really is everywhere and it seems
to be moving around in schools a lot and
then the children bring it home and the
adults get infected quite scary for
older adults but that seems to be the
pattern right now and uh it's it's it's
not easy because the kids can get quite
poorly but at least in my family
nobody's had any really untoward
consequences
and we're thankful for that it's always
great to talk to you doctor thank you
very much indeed for joining us thank
you thank you thank you for all you do
and thank you greetings to everybody
thank you doctor let's have a look at
some of the pictures making the
morning's papers should we here we go
one or two for you um starting with the
telegraph dramatic picture of a
firefighter walking past a bushfire in a
railway town in western australia my
goodness for the bird lovers out there
very good morning to you this one love
it
the daily mail has this story of a 71
year old swan whisperer from dorset who
visits the local river so much that the
swans have grown accustomed to his
presence nothing at all to do with the
food that he's got in his hands and the
mirror has this spread of the hazmat
olympics showing the extremely stringent
coving measures in place
in beijing during the winter olympics
shaken not stared and the guardian has
this stunning shot of the setting sun
over the channel wow that's an amazing
picture i absolutely love that i think
he might have popped a filter on that
what do you think
i don't know maybe being a little bit
unkind